♪
>> Laura: IN A FOX NEWS
EXCLUSIVE, REPUBLICANS ON THE
HOUSE SELECT SUB COMMITTEE ON
COVID RELEASED A REPORT TODAY
EXPOSING HOW THE CDC COORDINATED
WITH THE TEACHERS UNION TO SLOW
THE SCHOOL REOPENING PROCESS.
E-MAILS BETWEEN THE AFT, THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE AND THE CDC
SHOW THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP AT THE CDC PETITIONED
THE UNION TO IMPOSE LINE BY LINE
EDIT TO THE OPENING GUIDELINES.
SO HOW DO YOU OBTAIN SUCH SWAY?
IN 202099.9% OF THE AFT'S
DONATIONS WENT TO DEMOCRATS,
NEARLY $1 MILLION.
REPUBLICANS GOT $75.
AND THAT WAS FROM AN EMPLOYEE.
OF THE 25 BIGGEST RECIPIENTS OF
AFT CASH FOUR ARE DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS UP FOR REELECTION.
RAFAEL WARNOCK OF GEORGIA, MARK
KELLY OF ARIZONA, CATHERINE
CORTEZ OF NEVADA AND IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
HERE NOW THE TOP REPUBLICAN ON
THE COVID SUB COMETEE HOUSE
MINORITY WHIP STEVE SCALISE.
CONGRESSMAN THIS LEVEL OF
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
DEMOCRATS AND TEACHERS UNIONS
WHO HAVE THEM IN THEIR BAG
POCKETS, THIS IS NOT SCIENCE.
THIS IS POLITICS.
>> YEAH, LAUREN, WHAT WE EXPOSED
THROUGH THIS IS THAT IT WAS
POLITICAL SCIENCE, NOT MEDICAL
SCIENCE THAT THE CDC USED TO PUT
THEIR GUIDANCE OUT ON SCHOOL
REOPENINGS.
AND, IN FACT, CDC WAS GIVING
READY TO COME OUT WITH GUIDANCE
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN MORE
FAVORABLE TOWARDS OPENING
SCHOOLS AND THEN THE TEACHERS
UNIONS WERE GIVEN A WEEK OVER A
WEEK BEFORE IT CAME OUT, WERE
GIVEN A SNEAK COPY OF IT THAT NO
ONE ELSE COULD FIND AND SAID,
OKAY, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS?
AND WE HAVE UNCOVERED E-MAILS
BETWEEN THE CDC DIRECTOR AND THE
UNION PRESIDENT SAYING WAIT A
MINUTE, WE DON'T LIKE THIS.
WE WANT NEW LANGUAGE THAT MAKES
IT EASIER TO CLOSE SCHOOLS AND
THEY ACTUALLY, THE UNION, GAVE
DIFFERENT LANGUAGE TO THE CDC
AND THEN CDC'S FINAL LANGUAGE
WAS ALMOST WORD FOR WORD
VERBATIM OF WHAT THE UNION SAID.
I DON'T KNOW ANY OTHER GROUPS,
CERTAINLY PARENTS GROUPS, THAT
GOT THIS KIND OF VIP ACCESS AND
I ASKED THE CDC DIRECTOR TODAY
IN THE HEARING TO GIVE POE A
LIST OF ANYBODY ELSE THAT THEY
GAVE THIS KIND OF ACCESS TO THE
CHANGE THE DOCUMENTS.
>> Laura: WE HAVE ONE OF YOUR
EXCHANGES.
THIS IS WHEN YOU ASKED WA LESS
THANSKI ABOUT THE CDC'S JUST
PLAIN INVOLVEMENT WITH THE
UNIONS.
WATCH.
>> THESE WERE DISCUSSIONS THAT
HAPPENED IN THE BEGINNING OF
FEBRUARY OF 2021, DAYS AFTER I
ENTERED INTO THIS POSITION.
WE NEEDED TO GET OUR SCHOOLS
OPEN.
WE, IN THAT CONTEXT, ENGAGED, AS
WE OFTEN DO, WITH ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE IMPACTED BY OUR
GUIDANCE AND OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
AT THE AGENCIES.
>> Laura: FIRST OF ALL SHE'S
READING HER RESPONSE, SHE KNOWS
SHE'S IN HOT WATER SO YOU CAN
SEE HER READING IT.
SECOND OF ALL, THE TEACHERS
UNIONS WE KNOW FROM THE CHICAGO
EXPERIENCE CONGRESSMEN, THEY
NEVER WANT TO GO BACK.
IF THEY COULD STAY REMOTE
FOREVER, THE CROON ONWOULD BE
HAPPY TO STAY.
JUST LIKE YOUR COLLEAGUES NEVER
WANT TO COME BACK TO DO ACTUAL
VOTING IN PERSON.
SO WHY WE ASKED FOR THEIR
GUIDANCE IF THEY DON'T WANT TO
WORK.
>> YEAH, ULTIMATELY THEY SAID WE
NEED MORE GUIDANCE TO KEEP
SCHOOLS CLOSED AND MILLIONS OF
CHILDREN OUT OF SCHOOLS.
AND THIS IS ALL GOING ON IN THE
BACK DROP WHEN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS CALLING PARENTS
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS FOR GOING TO
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS.
SO I ASKED THE CDC DIRECTOR GIVE
ME NAMES OF PARENTS GROUPS THAT
YOU CONSULTED AND GAVE THE SAME
KIND OF VIP ACCESS.
THEY COULDN'T GIVE ME A NAME.
I SAID I WANT TO KNOW, LIKE WERE
PARENTS ALLOWED TO HAVE THE SAME
KIND OF ABILITY TO CHANGE THE
SCIENCE, LIKE THE UNIONS WERE
ABLE TO GIVE TO KEEP SCHOOLS
CLOSED AND SHE COULDN'T GIVE MOW
A SINGLE NAME BECAUSE IT WAS THE
UNION BOSSES WHO SAID, LOOK,
DON'T COME OUT WITH THIS UNTIL
YOU GIVE US NEW ABILITY TO SHUT
DOWN SCHOOLS, AND THEY PAID OFF
THEIR FRIENDS AND GAVE THEM THE
LANGUAGE.
>> Laura: I WILL SAY, IN
CLOSING, THAT MAGGIE HASSAN IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE, MARK KELLY IN
ARIZONA, CORTEZ MAST 0 IN NEVADA
YOU ARE PARTLY RESPONSIBLE YOU
GET THE DONATIONS IN THE
REACHERS UNIONS, WARNOCK AS
WELL.
VOTERS HAVE TO TAKE NOTICE.
YOUR KIDS WERE OUT O